I'm a female student in stem and I feel bombarded by all the feminist groups
trying to infantilize me.
How do I prevent them from turning me into an adult child?
You know,
one of the things that's really useful to do in university is to pick your peer
group.
When I went to university,
like I made new friends in university and that was really useful.
So I had my personal friends and they were people who were trying to aim at
something better than what they had,
something better than what they had left.
And that was a real relief to me.
I wrote about that in my new book too.
Um,
called make friends with people who want the best for you.
That's rule three.
Um,
but I also realized that when you went to university,
you picked your peers and in the stem fields what you should do is pick some
great scientists and those could be people that you just read books about.
Pick some great scientists,
man or some great engineers.
There's some great mathematicians,
cause I don't know where you are in the stem fields.
Pick some,
pick a hero or two or three and then make those of your peers right and don't
pay any attention to all the noise and Ruckus that you hear around you.
It's all nonsense anyways.
Partly what should happen when you go to university is that you should be
introduced to great people and those can be great people of the past.
They,
their spirits still live on in their work,
in their books,
and you can pick them as peers and just ignore all that idiot political
nonsense.
Well,
you straighten yourself out and learn to be great at what you do.
Develop a philosophy of greatness and that will keep the social justice warriors
at bay.